what um
advice would you give to a young person
today about their career about life
about uh how to survive in this world
full of suffering
yeah great um
[Laughter]
my advice is to get competent advice
don't listen to me don't listen to me
well you know i think
um my big
piece of advice these days
is you know again it's that the risk is
sounding
like a simpleton but it's to emphasize
a few things one is um
you know so one of your questions i
think was you know what's the meaning of
life and of course the existentialists
say
life has no meaning but it doesn't
follow from that that it's intrinsic
that it's meaningless you know what the
existential point
is not that life is meaningless
so much as it doesn't have one
inevitable and intrinsic meaning you
know which then
it opens up you know i think it was
kierkegaard who said consciousness gives
us the possibility of possibilities and
but there's another lunatic oswald
spangler who wrote a book called
decline of the west and he says that the
philosopher the german philosopher
guerta
he says the purpose of life is to live
and i let that's so that's one of my
pieces of advice
so the the possibility of possibilities
it's interesting so what do you do with
this kind of sea of possibilities
like well this is one of the when when
young folks
talk to me especially these days uh
is there swimming in a sea of
possibilities yeah well so this is
it's great and so that's another
existential point which is that
we yearn for freedom we react
vigorously when we perceive that our
choices have been curtailed
and then we're paralyzed by indecision
in the wake of seemingly unlimited
possibilities because we're not choking
on choice
and and i'm not sure if this is helpful
advice or not but what i say to folks is
that the fact of the matter is
is that you know for most people
choice is a first world problem and
sometimes the best
option is to do something
as silly as it sounds and then if that
doesn't work
do something else which just sounds like
my mom torturing me
uh when i was young but you know part of
the thing that
i find myself singularly ill-equipped
is that we're at the i may be at the
tail end
of the last generation of americans
where you like picked something and
that's what you did
like i've been at a job for 40 years
where you can expect to do better than
your parents because those days are gone
and where you can
make a comfortable inference that the
world in a decade or two
will have any remote similarity to the
one
that we now inhabit and so
but still you recommend just do yeah
and to do so i'm again i'm this is i'm
so
back to the heidegger guy because
all right i mean you know i consider
myself a professor
but what happens if most of the schools
go out of business
somebody else may consider themselves a
restaurant tour
but what happens if there's no more
restaurants
so what i this is negative advice but i
tell folks don't define yourself
as a social caricature yeah uh
don't don't limit
how you feel about yourself
by uh through identification
with a host of variables
that may be uncertain maybe temporary
and temporary what uh let's say
no but of course that gets back to your
point earlier lex where you're like yeah
but when you step
out of that it's extraordinarily
discombobulating
you